is there any verses of Abraham
worshiping other than the father Yes you
you aware that Jesus is known as the
word of God right all the prophets are
the word of God no no only Jesus this is
Genesis 15 verse1 after these things the
word of God the word of Yahweh came to
Abram in a vision and the word said fear
not Abram I am your Shield your reward
shall be great so now Abram is speaking
back to the word of God saying oh Lord
Yahweh oh Lord God what will you give me
for I continue childless and he the word
of the Lord he brought him outside and
said look toward the heaven and and and
Number the Stars Then he said to him so
shall your Offspring be and Abram
believed God believed Yahweh and he said
to him I am so this is the word of the
Lord saying talking again I am Yahweh
the Lord who brought you out from ER of
the Chaldeans to give you this land to
possess so the word of God comes to
Abram and Abram recognizes him as Lord
recognizes him as God and recognizes him
as the Creator who's going to give him
Offspring that's Jesus I will go ahead
and look over these what is your opinion
on the from Isaiah
29:12 nice okay Isaiah 29:12 let's go
ahead and read it because people have
brought this up before like zachar and
others we're going to actually start at
verse 9 is that okay go ahead all right
so verse n it says this astonish
yourselves and be astonished blind
yourselves and be blind be drunk but not
with wine stagger but not with strong
drink for the Lord has poured out upon
you a spirit of deep sleep and has
closed the eyes the prophets and covered
your heads the seers so already we're
starting off that God is saying that
these people are blind these people are
drunk but not with wine they stagger but
not with strong drink but it's a
spiritual blindness that God is putting
over these people especially their
prophets he's closed the eyes of these
prophets and covered the heads of the
seers verse 11 and the vision of all of
this has become to you like the words of
a book that is sealed when men give it
to one who can read saying read this he
says I cannot for it is sealed and when
they give the book to one who cannot
read saying read this he says I cannot
read so why is this happening why did
God stop his Revelation from coming to
these people and why did he blind the
prophets why did he close the eyes of
the seers it says and the Lord said
because this people draw near to me with
their mouth they honor me with their
lips while their hearts are far from me
and their and the fear Their Fear of me
is a commandment taught by men therefore
behold I will again do wonderful things
with this people with Wonder upon wonder
and the wisdom of their wise men Shall
Perish and the discernment of their
Discerning men shall be hidden so these
people that is that's being talked about
in Isaiah 29:12 are hypocrites they
honor God with their lips while their
hearts are not are far from him so they
Hypocrites they worship God in vain and
these are false prophets and false seers
who God has blinded you sure you want to
say that this is about Muhammad I didn't
make any claim I was just asking you
what your opinion on the verse was okay
just let you know whenever Muslims say
that this is about Muhammad this is what
they're saying they're saying that
Muhammad was a
hypocritical
um he was a hypocrite who worshiped god
with his mouth but was far from Far his
heart was far from him and was blinded
by God and given and and given spiritual
drunkenness
I see I see just wish I could look at my
on Tik Tok I didn't realize you can't do
both well you can take your time man
like you know there's no rush if you
want like to take a second to you know
go over your notes really quick like I
won't drop you you know take take your
time if you feel like you have something
in your notes that may help with you in
your conversation I'd love to actually
hear it love to in the meantime ladies
and gents make sure you guys are hitting
that like button do not out yourself as
a secret undercover Stone kisser we know
who you are so hit hit that button like
you fear Disobedience from right s quick
question go ahead I see you're quite
knowledgeable right barely but you know
you've been doing this for a long time
so when you do these debates do you
purposely say things to try and incite
people or antagonize or no yes so it is
like that's one of your methods right
yes to get you it starts the
conversation I I provoke you to have the
conversation I provoke you to have the
conversation so like when I say things
like the Quran is the Quran mentioned in
the Bible that provokes you to come up
and have a conversation so you're here
no no not that the undercover Stone
kisser oh what about that what's your
point of doing all that oh I I want
people to hit the like button so that
they we know that they're not you know
pagans you don't think you're above that
no I don't want anybody to be a pagans
so they got to hit the like button so so
Muslims are more pagans than Christians
in your opinion the word Pagan is coined
by Christians that's not what I ask
though well I mean we can't be pagans if
we're the ones who coined the term right
ask him what a pagan is follow if you
make up a word you can't be it
yeah do you know what a pagan is what
Idol worshipper or one who doesn't
worship the the god of Abraham Isaac and
Jacob okay so so who was the god of ab
Abraham the father Son and Holy
Spirit I'll put the Applause later is
there any verses of Abraham worshiping
other than the father yeah or Moses yes
want to see that yeah I got you watch
what Jesus says Jesus
you said you asked me to show you a
verse where Abraham right yeah okay
Abraham and Moses yeah Jesus mentions
Abraham and how and and and how he met
Abraham you didn't know that let me hear
the verse yeah so John chapter 8 no and
then after I show you this bro we got to
get right back to where the Quran me
where the Quran is mentioned in the
bible since it says it's mentioned in
the bible okay but I don't mind this
little segue all right so John chapter 8
is what it says here Habibi they
answered him Abraham is our father Jesus
said to them if you were Abraham's
children you would be doing the works
Abraham did but now you seek to kill me
a man who has told you the truth that I
heard from God this is not what Abraham
did you see how Jesus says that Abraham
didn't try to kill him when Abra when
Jesus came to him but how does that
verse show that Abraham worshiped I'll
get you there in a second I'll get you
there I just wanted to show you
that Jesus met Abraham and now now I'm
going to show you where but it does say
that he just you know preach the word of
God basically right absolutely it says
didn't kill him it doesn't say that and
and Abraham didn't try to kill
Jesus no no no read the verse one more
time you but but now but now you seek to
kill me a man who has told you the truth
that I heard from God this is not what
Abraham did so when Jesus came teaching
Abraham the truth Abraham didn't try to
kill Jesus matter of fact Jesus goes
into more detail watch he says this
which verse is this John what this is
John chapter 8 verse uh verse 40 okay I
can tell you by the way okay good now
I'm about to show you goes deeper into
it look he says uh the Jews this is drop
down to verse 52 the Jews said to him
now we know that you have a demon
Abraham died as did the prophets yet you
say if anyone keeps my word he will
never taste death are you greater than a
than our Father Abraham who died and the
prophets who died who do you make
yourself out to be Jesus answered if I
glorify myself my glory is nothing it is
my father who glorifies me of whom you
say he is our God but you have not known
him I know him if I were to say that I
do not know him I will be a liar like
you but I do know him and I keep his
word watch this your father Abraham
rejoiced that he would see my day he saw
it and was glad o Abraham was Abraham
rejoiced when he saw Jesus okay so with
these two verses let's say it is talking
about Abraham what do you mean let's say
it literally says it literally okay okay
no no look look no listen to the next
verse look it helps you look the Jews
understood what he was saying look so it
it says so the Jews said to him you are
not even 50 years old and you have seen
Abraham they understood what he was
saying and so watch how Jesus responds
Jesus said to them truly truly I say to
you before Abraham was I am oh that's
nasty that's nicey right there so they
picked up stones to throw at him okay we
take these verses at face value like
you're giving to me right yes in none of
those three verses does it mention him
worshiping them what you mean bro this
this is
crazy I'll let you oh I thought you was
asking a question okay sorry go ahead
yeah yeah so the two points the two main
points that I got from that is that
Abraham did not kill Jesus and then the
other one was that he met him or saw him
nowhere does it say that Abraham
worshiped the Son and the Holy Spirit
okay now let now let me show you now
where Jesus met Abraham let me show you
when he first met him now by the way as
as as maybe you you know this maybe you
don't I don't know I don't I'm not going
to assume anything for you but you
you're aware that Jesus is known as the
word of God right all the prophets are
the word of God no no only Jesus ask him
if Muhammad's the one prophets had
scriptures from from God they had
scriptures from God but they themselves
are not identified as the word of God
only Jesus is identified as the word of
God okay yeah but that's another that's
another tangent you're well it's not no
it's not it's it's essential to this
because I'm about to show you this
because you have to understand before I
show you this who the word is that's
Jesus okay all right so the word of God
is Jesus that's what it is that's in
John that's even in the Quran we already
know this all right now now let's see
who it is that appeared to Abraham when
did Jesus meet Abraham let me show you
let's go to Genesis we're going to the
Torah now Genesis 15 you ready yeah all
right now watch this now by the way let
me ask you this just really quick if if
you identify someone as God as your lord
and your God are you worshiping them if
you identify someone as your lord and
your God if you identify someone as God
you have worship yes that's basically a
form of worship I agree with you 100%
all right so look this is how it starts
off this is Genesis
15:1 after these things the word of God
the word of Yahweh came to Abram in a
vision so who came to Abram the word of
God and this is what he says quote fear
not Abram I am your Shield your reward
shall be very great but Abram said now
Abram speaking back to the word said can
you hear are you listening yeah go ahead
you you sound a little distracted like
you got to get this are you distracted
no no no go ahead go ahead okay so
you're with me the word the word of God
came to Abram right in a vision okay so
it says the word of the Lord came to
Abram in a vision and the word said fear
not Abram I am your Shield your reward
shall be great but Abram said so now
Abram is speaking back to the word of
God saying oh Lord Yahweh oh Lord God
what will you give me for I continue
childless and the heir of my house is
elizer I'm sorry El Eleazar of Damascus
and Abraham and Abram said behold you
have given me no Offspring and a member
of my household will be my Heir and
behold the word of the Lord came to him
this man shall not be your Heir your
very own son shall be your Heir and he
the word of the Lord he brought him
outside and said look toward the heaven
and and and Number the Stars if you are
able to number them then he said to him
so shall your Offspring be and Abram
believed God believed Yahweh and he
counted it to him as righteousness and
he said to him I am so this is the word
of the Lord saying talking again I am
Yahweh the Lord who brought you out from
ER of the Chaldeans to give you this
land to possess so the word of God comes
to Abram and Abram recognizes him as
Lord recognizes him as God and
recognizes him as the Creator who's
going to give him Offspring that's Jesus
okay I have to what verses were these
again this is Genesis chapter 15 you can
start at verse one and read all the way
uh you know all the way through okay so
Genesis chapter 15 and then the hold up
so Genesis chapter 15 and then what was
the other one that he spoke up before
that was that was John chapter 8 okay
verse 39 and 40 and also verses 52 to 55
okay 52 go to 58 was it 58 yeah before
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry yeah I'm
sorry it was uh 52 to 58 sorry not 55
got it I will go ahead and look over
these yeah man how often do you do these
lives all the time brother I'm uh I'm
usually live every Monday Wednesday and
Friday I have to go eat good talk um I
appreciate you comment at face value I'm
gonna go look over I'll come back to you
we'll see what time you say usually live
uh uh usually are you East Coast or West
Coast you in the US West Coast oh
perfect yeah so I'm usually live around
like 2:00 pm like 1:32 PM that's when I
usually
start okay sounds
good all right take care man have a good
uh lunch or dinner me too right
peace all
right he was great he was a great guy
the YouTu is about I'm not going to lie
to you he